[Music]
have you ever noticed the tips that the
Fast and the Furious writers took from
Point Break during rewrites and did you
know that George Lucas was disappointed
in how unoriginal the force awakens was
well these are 10 movies that completely
ripped off better ones Avatar is Dances
with Wolves in space both movies are
about a military man who goes native and
then faces off against the Army James
Cameron even admitted the similarities
when he asked about them pointing out
that it's kinda just a theme that comes
up in a lot of different movies and when
you consider that Avatar has been
accused of ripping off movies on
Pocahontas and FernGully the last
rainforest too yeah we can definitely
see that it's a popular storyline James
said that when he was putting together
the story of Avatar he gathered all this
stuff from different movies and then
tried to look at it through the lens of
Science Fiction by doing this James
wound up with a story that's described
as very different but still recognizable
in a universal story way maybe ripping
off a story can work out for you in its
own strained way but in our case the
main thing it'll get you is called out
by your series Creator wait can two
movies in the same franchise be
considered a rip-off well considering
it's in the Star Wars franchise we're
especially saying it is the plot to the
force awakens is basically the exact
same as the one from a new hope we're
introduced to a core Trio of Heroes we
have a masked shadowy bad guy and the
whole conflict hinges on what a Droid
knows that isn't even to mention the
Landscapes because jakku looks a lot
like Tatooine George Lucas even
expressed disappointment in how the
force awakens turned out saying there's
nothing new for George it was always
important that each movie visit a new
world or visual landscape but in the
force awakens there weren't enough
visual or technical leaps forward we
were basically just left stuck with all
these stories and images we've seen
before which gives us a little taste of
how audiences feel when they pick up
ratatouilling thinking that it's
Ratatouille have you ever seen an
animated movie that looks like something
you've heard of before except everything
seems a little off chances are it was
one of these movies low budget animated
knockoffs meant to trick parents into
thinking they're getting that thing
their kid keeps asking them about
ratatouilling's title and Chef rat
premise is meant to trick you into
thinking you're getting Ratatouille and
this isn't even the only example like
this there's chop kick Panda ripping off
Kung Fu Panda Tangled Up ripping off
Tangled and tappy toes ripping off Happy
Feet low budget remakes have become such
a nuisance to the house of mouse that
they even made a villain out of the
people who make them in Chippendale
Rescue Rangers now I run my own bootleg
movie studio we can tell they don't like
them very much but if you're liking what
you see here on our Channel we'd
recommend taking a chance to subscribe
because things move pretty fast and
furious around here have you ever
noticed that fast and the furious
endpoint break are basically the same
movie both of them are about an officer
of the law who's been forced to go
undercover performing an extreme sport
all in an effort to chase down the
criminal who also engaged in said
extreme sport at first everything seems
okay our officer is Finding Love within
the group and even getting along with
its leader he's convinced that a rival
group must be responsible for the crime
until uh-oh it's his own gang who's
responsible forcing our officer to
choose between Duty and loyalty in the
end he chooses the job but lets the
leader get away anyway Fast and the
Furious screenwriter Gary Scott Thompson
admitted to taking influence from Point
Break during rewrites revealing that he
was asked to give the movie more of a
moral center after the Columbine event
this led Thompson to sort of do what
they did in Point Break meaning saying
that they made Brian's character a cop
still this one has received less public
scrutiny than the next one which was
even called out by Quentin Tarantino so
how horrified were you when you first
heard of this premise a dystopian Future
run by a corrupt government who forces
teenagers to fight to the death until
there's only one winner all as a means
to prevent a revolution now am I
describing the premise to Battle Royale
or to the Hunger Games Battle Royale
technically came out first it's based on
a movie and manga from the year 2000
while the Hunger Games is based on a
novel that came out in 2008 and yet
according to the Hunger Games author
Suzanne Collins she'd never even heard
of Battle Royale the movie or Manga
until after she'd already turned her
book in but that hasn't stopped people
from pointing out the similarities even
famed director Quentin Tarantino felt
the need to weigh in and claim that the
Hunger Games just straight up ripped
Battle Royale off which is at least
better than ripping off a movie based
around a real tragedy Titan has suffered
a number of low budget rip-offs in its
day there's the animated legend of the
Titanic which for some reason features a
rapping dog don't sweat it forget it
and the even stranger animated Titanic
the legend goes on both of these movies
treat the tragedy of the Titanic with
all the sensitivity of an old-fashioned
Disney movie and they're a bit surreal
to watch outside of the realm of
animated Titanic knockoffs you also have
the live action Titanic 2. this one
doesn't actually have anything to do
with the James Cameron movie and is only
really named that to try and capitalize
on people who thought they'd missed the
release of the sequel to one of the
highest grossing movies of all time all
three of these movies feature a love
story set on a sinking ship but whether
or not that ship is the actual Titanic
depends on the rip-off so did you know
that McDonald's made a movie in the late
80s it's a movie called Mac and Me from
the very moment the movie's Creator RJ
Lewis set out with the one thought of
making the movie he'd apparently thought
it was time for another generation to
have its E.T okay maybe that idea could
have promised but who did he get for
financial backing of the thing hi kids
it's me Ronald McDonald this led to
moments in the Moment Like a full-on
dance number in the restaurant though
plot wise there were few differences in
Mac and Me from ET one thing that Lewis
did try to change was the alien's design
as he was very careful to make sure that
Mac did not resemble E.T instead he
wound up with something much more
hideous that straight up looks like it
could have come out in a horror movie
who do you find scarier Jason Voorhees
or Michael Myers well what if I told you
that one of them wouldn't have even
existed without the other when Halloween
was first released back in 1979 it was
dominating the box office the idea of a
silent stalker slowly and methodically
preying on a group of teenagers was
terrifying to many and it was one that
inspired the mind of one young director
named Sean s Cunningham according to
writer Victor Miller he received a call
from Cunningham around this time when he
suggested that the two of them team up
to make a movie that would rip off
Halloween and hopefully get in on its
success obviously their idea idea worked
and Horror history had forever made at
least Friday the 13th had the good
graces of letting Halloween come out
first but in our next case we'll be
talking about a ripoff that came before
the better one our next two entries are
real chicken and egg scenarios did
Atlantic Rim Riff Off Pacific Rim or is
it the other way around technically
Atlantic Rim was released several weeks
before Pacific Rim was but considering
how low budget it is compared to
Guillermo del Toro's painstakingly
crafted Blockbuster most people accept
that Atlantic Rim was quickly put
together to ride in on the coattails of
a more successful movie both are about
giant reptilian monsters fighting
equally large robots but in the case of
the Atlantic Rim those robots sort of
resemble the animated Transformers from
our childhood and the CGI on the
monsters isn't much better the acting in
this movie is so terrible all right we
don't get out of here on things that
real quick we're gonna burn them that
you're definitely better off sticking
with the movie it ripped off a group of
small mischievous creatures are set
loose on the streets of America did I
just describe the plot of Critters or
Gremlins Critters director Stephen
Herrick claimed that the first draft to
his script had been written months
before Gremlins even entered into
production and that rewrites had even
been done later on to make sure the two
movies had nothing in common but we are
still able to see them right on the
screen Critters wasn't even the only
movie to have ripped off Gremlins in the
80s from Ghoulies to hobgoblins everyone
wanted to try their hand at mischievous
little monsters though Joe Dante didn't
seem to mind too much when asked about
rip-offs of his work the Gremlins
director said it's a grand cinematic
tradition before pointing out I started
my career with a rip-off piranha which
was a rip-off of Jaws so I don't have
much street cred to complain about
people ripping me off it seems one thing
is for sure if you make a great movie
somebody will rip it off which of these
movies on this list were you most
surprised by and are there any examples
that we should have included we're all
fans of film here so make sure to join
us in the discussion in the comment
section down below